a growing number of public health
officials around the country are asking
Americans to use their smartphones to
help stop the corona virus from
spreading at least ten states are
offering or planning to offer cell phone
apps to track people who may have been
exposed to the virus this is all part of
a process we told you about before
contact tracing
but privacy is a concern and so far
getting people to use those apps has
been a challenge can we ask you three
quick questions about technology
Americans aren't too fond of being
followed around certainly not by me how
comfortable would you be if I were to
give you a tracking device like this and
monitored your movements throughout the
day not comfortable not comfortable all
no not by elected officials either
whatever government were tracking all of
your movements and who you come in
contact with still wouldn't feel
comfortable but there is some wiggle
room at least it seems if a public
health department is involved what if
that Public Health Department we're
using your phone to track whether or not
you were in contact with somebody with
Kovac 19:00 okay and that makes a
difference that's a big difference a
huge difference at least 10 states are
now hoping that difference is enough to
convince people to download a kovat 19
tracking app promising to warn people of
possible exposures while guarding their
privacy it's like an insurance policy
right you hope you never have to use it
Vern dosh leads the contact tracing
effort in North Dakota
he says the state's care 19 app was
meant to help with traditional contact
tracing it uses location tracking
technology to build a digital log of a
person's movements which they can then
share with investigators if they choose
we knew that basing an app on GPS there
were going to be a certain percent of
the population that was going to be very
leery of that for the people who are
skeptical what is your promise to the
residents of North Dakota about how
you'll protect who they are and where
they go the privacy pledge Tony is very
straightforward and that is that
no personal data is shared since the
launch of care 19 in early April though
fewer than 5% of North Dakota residents
have downloaded the app revelations in
recent years about tech companies
harvesting personal data haven't helped
unfortunately there have been some bad
actors in technology that have damaged
the trust that is so critical in the
successful deployment of these apps now
Google and Apple's say they may have a
solution
they co-developed a tracking technology
that's based not on GPS but on Bluetooth
users who test positive for kovat 19 can
anonymously notify the owners of other
phones that have been in close contact
and receive anonymous notifications in
term all without giving the data to
governments or companies North Dakota
will soon release a second app that
incorporates this technology what makes
you as a representative of the
government of North Dakota comfortable
with a private company like Google and
Apple building something that's going to
monitor the movements of your residents
that's that's a very good question there
is a perception that maybe those
companies are not to be trusted but we
have worked so closely with them Tony we
understand how they're using the
technology they have been
extraordinarily diligent and we really
respect that but it only works if people
decide to use it and while some
Americans are resigned to being tracked
I think it's fine because all the apps
are use like Google Maps Waze snapchat
they're probably always tracking our
information and where we're going all
the time
it's another app really is gonna make a
difference others are prone to resist
and in my opinion I think this
particular app because I've been reading
about it is a gateway to a chip they
want to put in my arm and I'm not a
conspiracy person government chip right
yeah I think it's more of a security
issue beyond Kovan the question is how
many are in the middle whether people
like Verne dodge can win them over what
is your message to those people on the
fence about downloading
we absolutely understand their hesitancy
or their reluctance to download the app
but in times like this when lives are at
stake when our ability to open the
economy is at stake every single
download matters it's a part of our
personal responsibility to be able to
leverage those technology tools the best
we can and hopefully we'll never have to
use them hopefully and I know this issue
really divides people Gail and Anthony
there there are some who just will not
put an app on their phone that they know
is tracking them so I just want to let
people know that they don't have to open
their Android or their Apple phone right
now and turn off anything if they
haven't downloaded a Health Department
app they're not currently being tracked
so that's not a worry but I will say
Gail when you're at state where we live
comes out with their app based on what
I've seen I feel good about using it as
part of combatting Coby 19 yes I would
sign hello my name is Gayle sign me up I
know this is very naive but I always
believe people who have nothing to hide
hide nothing and I'm thinking these this
is a very different territory that we're
in now where you say lives are at stake
Security's at stake that said I think if
you engage you should be worried about
your privacy I think you're giving up a
lot but I think the positives far
outweigh the negatives for me anyway
it'll be interesting to see how this
turns out Tony it's a personal decision
for everyone that is